Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's March 29, 2023.
We're here in ActInf
GuestStream number 40.1 with Wanja Wiese.
We're going to be hearing a presentation
in the first section and then having a
discussion.
So thank you, Wanja, for joining.
Again, really looking forward to your
presentation.
Wanja: Thank you very much.
So this presentation is based on a
preprint that can be found at Phil
Archive.
And this is work in progress.
And I probably or hopefully upload a
revised version of this preprint in a few
weeks.
So if you're watching this or if you're
reading the preprint and have any
comments or questions, feedback is very
much welcome.
And I'm also, again, grateful for having
the opportunity to present here because
I'm really looking forward to the
discussion and any comments that people
may have while watching this video.
So do contact me if you have questions or
comments.
Now I want to start this presentation
with an idea from this wonderful novella
by Tet Qiang, The Lifecycle of Software
Objects.
And if you're not familiar with the
novella, it doesn't matter.
So there are some digital entities, or
Digians as they are called in the
novella, who at first live in a purely
virtual environment.
So these are virtual entities like
virtual pets, and human users can
interact with them in a virtual
environment.
Then in some passages of the novella,
there are scenes in which some Digians
are, as it were, downloaded from this
purely virtual environment and are
implemented in a physically embodied
robot.
So the program that is running within
this computer simulation and is
controlling the purely virtual body is
then downloaded into a physically
embodied computer and is controlling a
physical robot which can interact with
its physical environment, non virtual
environment, in the same way in which the
virtual agent, the virtual digient,
interacts with the virtual environment.
And I find this idea really fascinating
and powerful.
So the novella suggests that these
virtual entities are conscious and that
they can switch back and forth, as it
were, between this purely virtual
environment and the physical non virtual
environment.
And the idea is that these entities
remain conscious when they're in the
robot, but also when they return to the
virtual environment.
And to some people it may be unintuitive
or counterintuitive that a purely virtual
entity in a simulated environment can be
conscious, but maybe some of these people
will find it less counterintuitive to
imagine a conscious robot.
And so the the idea is is fascinating to
me because it suggests that if you can
switch back and forth from the virtual
environment to the physical environment
and in the other direction, it really
doesn't matter where the software is
implemented, the system remains
conscious.
And I will come back to this idea at the
end of my presentation and we will see
what the account that I'm presenting here
suggests with respect to this scenario.
So this is the overview of my
presentation, which is based on the
preprint.
I'm just omitting a lot of details.
I'll start by saying just a few things
about the free energy principle.
Then I will ask what is the difference
between an unconscious simulation of a
conscious system and a conscious
computational system?
Or in other words, what's the difference
between what is called weak and strong
artificial consciousness?
So strong artificial consciousness is an
actually conscious artificial system and
weak artificial consciousness is
constituted by an visual system that
maybe behaves as if it were conscious or
that simulates a conscious being but is
not actually conscious.
And I'm interested in the question what's
the difference?
And a particular version of this question
is whether a computer simulation in a
computer with a Bonoman architecture can
be conscious.
So I start with the free energy principle
and I don't want to go into the details.
So we start with a description of a
physical system.
So the X is the the physical system.
And the fundamental assumption is that
the dynamics, the physical dynamics of
this system can be decomposed into two
components.
So we on the one hand have a
deterministic flow term f and then some
noise term, stochastic noise term.
So we end up with a stochastic
differential equation which describes how
the physical system evolves over time.
The further assumption is that we can
decompose the states of the system into
internal states mu, external states ETA,
sensory states S and active states A,
which together the sensory and active
states together constitute the blanket
states B.
And this then is a particular system
system that can be partitioned into
internal and external states, separated
by blanket states.
And a further assumption is that the
dynamics of this system can also be
partitioned in the following sense that
we can decompose this flow term into
individual flow terms for the different
states.
So we have a flow term for internal
states mu and can also describe the
dynamics of internal states in terms of
such a differential equation here.
Okay, so these are just technical
fundamental assumptions made by the free
energy principle.
But then interesting thing starts here
when we look at how else we can describe
internal states and the dynamics of
internal states.
So the idea is that we can map internal
states mu to probability distributions.
So this is your formulation in terms of
states.
And then the idea is that at every point
in time the system will be in certain
states, so there will be internal states
relative to each time point and we can
map each of these states to some
probability distribution Q of external
states given blanket states.
Okay, so we can do that, but then the
question is why should we do that?
And the idea is that maybe we can
redescribe the flow term, which is
essential for characterizing the dynamics
of internal states.
Can we redescribe this flow term in terms
of the probability distribution encoded
by internal states and the free energy
principle?
Answers.
Yes, we can rewrite this term in terms of
a variational free energy functional,
which specifies how the probability
distribution q, which is parametrized by
mu, and thereby also how mu changes over
time.
So we can reformulate the physical
dynamics of internal states.
We can rewrite the flow term in terms of
variational free energy or in terms of
minimizing variational free energy with
respect to a probability distribution
encoded by internal states.
And this is then called Bayesian
mechanics.
And it's called Bayesian mechanics
because minimizing variation of the
energy involves minimizing a divergence
term between the internally encoded
probability distribution q and a
posterior over external states given
blanket states.
Okay, so to sum this up, I will give
these ideas some labels.
So, I've already talked about the
physical dynamics, and these are the
dynamics of a particular system described
by a stochastic differential equation
involving a flow term and a noise term.
And recall that a particular system is a
system that can be partitioned into
internal, external, and blanket states,
and then, according to the free free
energy principle, can redescribe these
physical dynamics in terms of as
computational dynamics.
We can reformulate them in terms of a
description of the system's internal
states, Mu, as performing approximative
Bayesian inference by minimizing
variation of free energy with respect to
a probability density encoded by mu.
So, in short, we can reformulate the
physical dynamics as a computational
process that involves a form of Bayesian
inference.
Now, a further assumption that I want to
make here is that we can capture the
computational correlates of consciousness
in terms of the computational dynamics as
described by the free energy principle.
So here the computational correlates of
consciousness, or Cccs, are defined as
the computational dynamics of a physical
system, of a conscious physical system,
as specified by the free energy
principle.
So this is not just any physical system,
it's a conscious physical system.
Forgot to add this on the slide.
All right, so given these initial
assumptions and definitions, can we say
something about the difference between
weak and strong artificial
consciousness?
And I think we can.
So let's start with the idea of a
computational call it of consciousness.
Computations are medium independent, so
it's plausible that a digital computer
can implement computational correlates of
consciousness.
But then the question if we want to
distinguish weak from strong artificial
consciousness is, is every system that
implements Cccs conscious, or do systems
have to implement these computations in
the right way?
And what would that be?
To better understand this question, I
find it useful to look at this diagram
and see where we started.
So we have a description of a conscious
system's physical dynamics in the bottom
left.
And then according to the free energy
principle, we can reformulate this,
redescribe this as some computational
dynamics.
And by assumption, these include the
computational correlates of
consciousness, and they must be
implemented by the physical dynamics of
the conscious system.
Now, given that these are medium
independent properties.
They can also be instantiated by other
systems.
And here I'm assuming that these
computations can also be implemented by a
digital computer.
And the digital computer, as a physical
system, has some physical dynamics.
And if we can apply the drainage
principle to it, we can reformulate these
physical dynamics as computational
dynamics.
And so then the question becomes, do
these computational dynamics, do they
include the computational correlates of
consciousness, whatever they are?
So this is a crucial question that we
have to answer if we want to know what
the difference between weak and strong
artificial consciousness is.
Maybe there is no difference.
So before I present an argument to the
effect that in general, the computational
dynamics of a digital computer will not
entail the computational corals of
consciousness, before I present this
argument, I will present some
observations on the free energy
principle.
So note that systems that conform to the
French principle sustain their existence
by minimizing variation of free energy,
but the reverse does not hold.
So you can run simulations of agents that
minimize variation of free energy, and
you can do that on a computer which does
not thereby sustain its existence.
So it would continue to exist regardless
of whether it runs these simulations or
not.
Okay, just to illustrate this with a
quotation which may be familiar to many
so this is by Chris Mattel.
Many theories in the biological sciences
are answers to the question, what must
things do in order to exist?
The French principle turns this question
on its head and asks, if things exist,
what must they do?
More formally, if we can define what it
means to be something, can we identify
the physics or dynamics that a thing must
possess?
And Jacob Howie puts a similar point as
follows.
The free energy principle analyzes the
concept of existence of particular self
organizing systems.
So the idea is that continuing to exist,
sustaining one's existence, means
minimizing variational free energy.
And so any processes that contribute to
minimizing variation of fringe thereby
contribute to the sustained existence of
the system.
But such processes can also be
implemented in other ways by different
systems which do not thereby sustain
their existence.
And this, I want to suggest, is a crucial
difference between systems that merely
simulate conscious systems and systems
that actually are conscious.
Okay, I will hopefully clarify this idea
in a moment by presenting an argument.
But before that, I need a definition.
So I want to introduce a notion of
intrinsic computation.
And these are just computations that
contribute to the sustained existence of
the systems.
So these are the computations that figure
in the computational reformulation of the
system's physical dynamics.
According to the free energy principle,
an intrinsic here means these
computations are observer independent.
So it's not the case that we as observers
say, okay, we can interpret the system as
performing these computations, or it's
useful for us to use them as
computational devices.
The idea is that these computations are
processes that are intrinsic to the
system, that only depend on properties of
the system itself and not on relations
that the system has to observers or to
other beings.
Okay, so here's the argument, which in a
way is already contained in the
preprint.
But I did not formulate the argument in
this explicit way.
So I'm grateful to Tommy corBack, who
provided some comments on my preprint and
who also suggested a reconstruction of
the argument that I'm presenting in the
preprint.
And this formulation here is based on
Tomic's suggestions.
And I hope this clarifies the argument
that I'm putting forward developing in
the preprint.
Okay, so the first assumption, and the
argument is a version of computationalism
about consciousness.
So the idea is that causal roles that
characterize phenomenal consciousness are
medium independent and can be captured in
terms of computation.
These are computational correlates of
consciousness.
So the idea is that consciousness does
not require a particular type of
substrate.
It can be, in principle, can be realized
by different types of system as long as
these systems implement the right
computations.
So this assumption, as I intended, does
not entail that implementing the right
computations is sufficient for being
conscious.
It's here just meant as a necessary
condition.
And the idea is that there are
informative, interesting computational
crawlers of consciousness and they can,
in principle be performed implemented by
different types of system.
Then comes the second assumption,
according to which every conscious system
and its computational correlates can be
described by a mechanical theory that
conforms to the free energy principle.
So this is an assumption about the scope
of the free energy principle.
And it's at least clear that the free
energy principle is intended to have a
very wide scope that's not meant just to
apply to the human brain.
It's not just meant to apply to living
systems, but it's meant to apply to a
very wide class of self organizing
systems.
And this idea or this intention that the
free energy principle has a very wide
scope is also evidenced by the fact that
recent formulations and recent
developments in research on the free
energy principle seek to relax certain
assumptions.
That were made in previous version so as
to make the free energy principle
applicable to a very wide class of
systems and not, for instance, just to
systems in non equilibrium steady state.
For instance, just as one example.
All right, so the idea is that we can
apply the free energy principle to
conscious systems.
And that means we can move from a
description of physical dynamics to a
description of computational dynamics.
And these will include computational
correlates of consciousness.
The third assumption makes a connection
between intrinsic computation and
consciousness.
A system is conscious only if it sustains
its existence by virtue of the
computational correlates.
It realizes such computational correlates
of consciousness are intrinsic
computations, computations that
contribute to the sustained existence of
the system.
So if a system follows certain or
implements certain physical dynamics,
which under the Fep can be described as
computational dynamics that entail
computational correlates of
consciousness, whatever they are, then
the system is conscious.
But it's only conscious if it's in this
direction.
So, in principle, it's possible to
implement the same computational
processes without being conscious.
And this becomes clear in conclusion or
described by conclusion one, it's
possible to instantiate computational
calls of consciousness in a physical
system without instantiating
consciousness, namely, if realizing the
computational correlates of consciousness
does not contribute to the sustained
existence of the system.
So assuming that a digital computer can
perform the computations that
characterize consciousness in conscious
systems, it's likely, according to this
proposal, it's likely that the computer
will not thereby be conscious because it
could implement different computations.
It really doesn't matter what
computations it performs.
It will continue to exist as a physical
system regardless of the computational
processes that it implements.
So it does not sustain its existence by
virtue of the computations it performs.
All right?
And a condition that is entailed by this
is that from the point of view of the
free energy principle, computation of the
physical system is intrinsic if it
matches the system's physical dynamics.
And this will be important also for the
question about consciousness in computer
simulations.
So the second conclusion that I want to
draw here is that computers with a von
Neumann architecture cannot implement
intrinsic computations because their
physical dynamics induces a causal flow
that is different from the causal flow
entailed by the computational dynamics.
So there's no match between the physical
and the computational dynamics or between
the physical dynamics and the
computations that are performed within
the computer simulation.
I will unpack this in the third part of
my presentation.
So could there be consciousness in a
computer simulation, in a computer with a
classical architecture?
So this is an idea that I already
presented in previous works.
So in a system that conforms to the free
energy principle, there's a basic flow
from internal states via active states to
external states and from external states
via sensory states to internal states.
So we have these circular dynamics.
And in a computer with a von Neumann
architecture, the basic causal flow is a
bit different.
So we have memory and we have a separate
processing unit and units that store the
values of the different variables of
internal that stand for internal,
external and blanket states.
They are in the memory unit, and there's
no direct causal interaction between
these units, but it's always mediated by
the CPU.
So that's a basic idea.
And therefore, there's difference in a
causal flow.
And this means that the physical dynamics
of the computer does not have a or the if
we want to reformulate the physical
dynamics of the computer in terms of
minimizing variation of the energy, we
end up with something that cannot match.
We end up with computational processes
that cannot be identical to the
computations that are simulated by the
computer because then there would have to
be a match between the states that
represent the probability distributions
encoded by internal states and the
internal states themselves.
Okay?
So from this, I suggest we can derive two
necessary conditions for consciousness.
One is the flow condition.
The causal flow of a physical system's
computational dynamics, which may realize
computational correlates of consciousness
must match the causal flow of the
system's physical dynamics.
And then there's a second condition which
I call the existential condition.
A physical system sustains existence by
virtue of realizing computational
correlates of consciousness.
So if it's a conscious physical system,
then this is the case.
All right, just a few observations or
notes about this.
So a system can satisfy the first the
flow condition without thereby satisfying
the existential condition.
So the existential condition is stronger
than the flow condition.
But if a system satisfies the existential
condition, then it also satisfies the
flow conditions.
And not all systems that satisfy both of
these conditions are conscious.
In other words, neither of them are
sufficient for consciousness.
These are really just strictly necessary
conditions for consciousness.
All right, let me return to the idea that
I presented in the beginning from Pat
Xiang's novella.
So from the point of view of the account
that I presented here, is it possible to
download virtual entity to a robot?
And will it be conscious, or can it be
conscious in the simulation?
So I should just assume here that these
systems satisfy the flow condition first
condition.
So assuming that this is a very special
computer simulation in which the physical
states that represent internal, external
and blanket states, that these physical
states also directly causally interact
with each other and according to the
account proposed here, the computer
simulation.
There would still not be consciousness in
the computer simulation because the
computer does not sustain its existence
by virtue of performing these
computations.
It could also run different simulations
which do not involve these digital
entities, and it would continue to
exist.
So according to the account presented
here, there would not be consciousness in
this system.
And if we download the part of the
program that controls the virtual agent
and download it to a physically inverted
robot, could that robot be conscious?
Well, in principle it could if the robot
sustains its existence by virtue of
performing the computations that are also
performed by the computer simulation.
And now this result might be a bit
strange because contrary to what the
novella suggests, it would suggest that
the system cannot switch back and forth
between the virtual and the physical non
virtual environment without losing
consciousness.
And I admit that that is a kind of
counterintuitive implication.
But maybe it only seems
counterintuitive.
Maybe it's not technically possible to
download a virtual entity which was
trained in a purely virtual environment
and download it to implement it in a
physical robot and thereby allowing the
physical robot to interact with its
environment in the same way as a virtual
entity can interact with a virtual
environment.
So I know that in robotics there's a
certain strategy to train robots or to
develop the controller of the physical
robot, naming that you first train it in
a virtual and a simulated environment,
and then you use that to control the
robot.
Maybe this only works for robots that
kind of have certain limitations in their
sensory motor abilities.
Maybe it doesn't work for highly
sophisticated robots that are more like
conscious organisms which can react
adaptively and very flexible in a
flexible way, can interact flexibly with
the environment on the basis, maybe, of
effectively guided, effectively shaped
representations.
So this would be maybe an empirical
hypothesis derived from my account that
this strategy, this symptom real strategy
of simulating an entity in a virtual
environment and then applying that to a
physical entity, the prediction would be
that this has at some point reach limits
and will not be successful.
If, on the other hand, this hypothesis or
this prediction will turn out to be
false, I think we should reconsider the
account that I'm presenting here.
Okay, let me conclude.
I've asked what is the difference between
weak and strong artificial
consciousness?
And the suggestion is that it's about
intrinsic computation.
That's the difference.
Actually.
Conscious systems sustain their
existence, at least in part by virtue of
performing certain computations.
And a mere simulation of a conscious
system does not thereby sustain its
existence.
It could also perform different
computations and still continue to
exist.
This condition entails the flow
condition, which is important for the
second question.
Could a computer simulation in a computer
with a Van Neumann architecture be
conscious?
No, because it violates the flow
condition.
Okay, here's an ad for the journal
Philosophy and the Mind Sciences, which
I'm running together with Sasha Fing,
Jennifer Wind, and Regina Farpri, and I
thank you for your attention.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
I'm just getting my video back in the
game while I'm getting everything back on
the stream.
First, just thank you for the
presentation and wanted to pick up with
that robotics intro and conclusion.
To what extent does the embodiment in the
robot matter beyond the ability of the
virtual simulation to do things like
eject.
The CD drive or ultimately do physical
things, just not the kinds of physical
things that we see human children do,
like play with toys?
When you were thinking about the
virtualized simulation, were you thinking
about one that had no access to sensors
and actuators?
Or what happens when the digital
simulation also has access in some
limited way to the ability to sense and
act on the outside world?
If you have any thoughts sorry about
that.
On the stream, it was audible, but not to
you.
But now I've resolved the zoom.
So we can, from your consciousness
perspective, consider it a new question.
So I just wanted to pick up with that
robotics example, a digital simulation
may still have sensors engaging with the
world and may still be able to undertake
actuation if only something like flipping
a switch on a processor.
So what exactly about the embodiment do
you think matters for it to have that
kind of adaptivity and maybe even open
endedness and learning that you pointed
to as an important property?
Wanja: Yeah, good question.
I think there are many different aspects
that you're touching upon.
Let me start with this one.
So I mentioned my correspondence with
Atomic corBack and one thing that he
suggested was that couldn't we regard a
language model as a system that has
certain sensory motor abilities so it can
interact with physical environment via a
linguistic interface?
So it receives text as input and it
outputs text as outputs text.
And can't we regard this as sensing and
acting?
I think it's similar to one of the
aspects that your question touches upon.
So what is it about the embodiment?
And can there be different forms of
embodiment that might still lead to
consciousness?
And I don't have a full reply to this,
just two things that I would mention
here.
The first is that there are certainly
some analogies between what a language
model does when it interacts with a user
and a system that maybe an organism that
interacts with its environment via
perception and action.
But there are also some dis analogies.
So when it comes to interacting with the
environment, when an organism interacts
with its environment, their temporal
constraints, it's really important that
it does the right thing at the right time
and reacts fast enough and so on.
And for a language model, that does not
play a big role.
So there's one difference.
And then there's also a difference in the
format of the representations.
And in principle you could say, okay, why
does this matter?
And maybe in the end it doesn't.
But I just want to mention that there's
some crucial dis analogies that I think
would be important to take into
consideration and evaluate.
Then there's a question, okay, is there
something about these more low level
sensory motor skills that is crucial when
it comes to consciousness?
Now, on the one hand, we know that an
organism can be conscious without having
any language skills, without being able
to speak or understand language.
So this is why when it comes to functions
of consciousness, for instance, people
don't look for or usually don't look for
linguistic abilities, but more for
sensory motor abilities or forms of
learning that enable or improve
interaction with the world.
This is one thing, but of course, in
principle it could still be that a system
that lacks these low level, low level
skills is conscious.
But then I would say if it's possible to
be conscious without having these sensory
remote skills, then it's not really about
any ability for interaction with an
environment that a system is conscious.
But then it's merely because of some
internal computations that the system
performs.
So if you're thinking about systems that
might be islands of awareness, systems
that don't receive any sensory input and
don't produce any motor output, then I
wouldn't want to rule out that such
systems are conscious and these such
systems don't have any ways of
interacting with their environment.
So I'm happy to accept that interaction
with the environment is not required for
consciousness.
But coming back to language models this
would mean that being able to interact
with users using language is similarly
not required for consciousness.
So I would say if such a system is
conscious then it's not because of its
ability to interact with the environment,
but because of the internal processes.
And what may be crucial is not the actual
interaction with the environment but just
the potential for interaction with the
physical alignment.
And then it might in principle it might
very well be that a language model can
facilitate interaction with the physical
environment, for instance if it's
connected to a physically embodied
robot.
And I mean, there's research going on on
such things.
Researchers who try to improve the
abilities of their robots by connecting
them or interfacing them with a language
model which can then help translate
commands into motor sequences.
What this suggests is that maybe there
are some crucial types of representation
or computational processes that are
actually already implemented in language
models or in other systems that don't
really not directly interact with the
physical environment.
And I'm happy to accept that.
But I would add that at least according
to the proposal that I've presented here,
you need something more for that.
And you need really it's not sufficient
to just implement these computations, but
they must have a meaning for the system
itself, in the sense that the system will
sustain its existence by virtue of these
processes if it is connected to the real
physical environment.
Now maybe that I've not addressed every
aspect of your question so feel free to
restate your question.
Daniel: It's great.
It got to a great place because I wanted
to follow up with this intrinsic
computation concept.
So you mentioned that they're observer
independent to the extent that anything
or any process can be and that these are
the kinds of processes that actually
enable the persistence of that thing
according to the Fep.
And so I was thinking about this first in
a bottom up way.
Like this is the firmware, this is the
Linux kernel.
This is the kind of enabling software
that is supporting potentially extraneous
higher order functions and that is
allowing some kind of separation or
delineation between what we can say are
like the vital and intrinsic like almost
the homeostatic functions and then second
order functions.
But then I thought about the ecology that
the computation is deployed in and so
let's just say that the software is being
the software simulation is being used in
a scientific context.
Or to run photoshop and another cognitive
agent keeps that simulation alive because
it's performing some function.
And so from that bottom up sense the
Photoshop program is not the Linux kernel
so it's not like the Photoshop.
Like the Photoshop in principle is not
sustaining the persistence of the entity
in a bottom up fashion.
However, in deployment it actually
becomes a necessary condition imposed
externally and that will also be
extremely observer dependent or
subjective.
So how do we think about in standard
modern computers or in Wetware?
What are these intrinsic computations?
Wanja: Thank you.
That's a great question.
I can say more about intrinsic
computation in a moment but just one
comment before that.
So I think you're touching on a very
important issue and that's a question by
what is a system in the first place.
So if we want to consider the question
what kinds of entities can be conscious?
And we have to first say okay, what are
the entities that we're looking in at in
the first place?
What are these things?
And why can't we look at a piece of
software or some process that is running
an app that a user is using?
What was the example that you gave?
Photoshop or something?
So why can't we regard Photoshop and a
particular instance of this software as a
system which exists for some time and it
will continue to exist if it's useful for
a human being and it's useful by virtue
of the computation computations that are
realized by it.
And so can't we say that the system
sustains its existence by virtue of the
computations that it performs?
That's I think a very crucial question
because it's so fundamental what is a
system?
And currently I think that the free
energy principle is sufficient to answer
this question but it may be that it's
still too general.
So I dean the free energy principle gives
us an answer to the question if something
exists, what must it do?
And so it analyzes this notion of the
continued existence of self organizing
systems and maybe it does apply to the
processes that implement photoshop in the
computer of a human being who uses this
software.
And if that's the case, then I think we
have to add some further constraints it
may be necessary to add some further
constraints on the kinds of systems that
we want to regard as potentially
conscious or that we want to consider
when it comes to the question what kinds
of systems can be conscious?
And one suggestion or idea that I think
would be worthwhile to explore here is to
investigate to what extent something like
the free energy integrated information
theory may complement the free energy
principle in this regard.
Because integrated information theory has
a very strong emphasis on the notion of
existence, of what it means to exist,
what it means to be what it means to
intrinsically exist, as it were, and not
just in the eye of a beholder.
And maybe we need to add constraints from
something like integrated information
theory, which would then tell us what
types of systems really exist.
And then maybe it would say, okay, the
processes that are implementing Photoshop
in this computer don't really exist in an
intrinsic sense.
Yeah.
So this would then be my suggestion to
add some constraints.
But of course, you could say, well, no,
such constraints are completely
unnecessary.
We don't need to exclude certain systems,
and we can regard the processes that
implement Photoshop as a real system that
sustains its existence.
But my intuition would be, at least
currently, that such processes would, at
least in a classical system with a
classical hardware, would be too
scattered, and there would be so many
physical processes interfering, as it
were, that you can regard this as a
separate thing which is distinct from
other things that are happening in the
computer.
But I would say this is more an observer
dependent property.
Those processes, they're so entangled
with other processes in the physical
system that they are not particular
systems in the sense of the free energy
principle.
Daniel: Awesome.
And again, kind of journeys us to another
question about the topological or
geometric concordances between physical
and computational dynamics.
And it made me think of a few different
kinds of systems.
The von Neumann architecture described
with the CPU and the Ram regular desktop
computer situation.
Of course, we have unconventional
computing paradigms, quantum and analog
computers.
We have the brain and the SPM package in
which statistical inferences help us
model how brain regions that aren't
connected through, for example, axons can
still have an edge in a Bayesian graph.
They could still have a causal effective
or functional connectivity without being
structurally connected and vice versa.
And then to kind of bring it back to the
computer and what you brought up about
whether or not those processes would be
too scattered, what about a computer,
either a distributed computing cluster or
a strict virtualization scheme on the
computer such that certain variables were
isolated?
Would it be enough for the system to have
some kind of constraint, again through a
physical networked layout or through a
virtualized system so that the
computational flow and the causal flow
could be played with in a different way?
And then how would we know?
What would we be looking for?
Surely not simply test retest accuracy or
efficiency in some way.
That's not what consciousness is.
So, I mean, it really comes down to what
are we looking for or talking about if we
did have the ability to design different
systems that did have different overlap
with their computational and structural
aspects.
Wanja: Yeah, great question.
I think it's very important to look at
different types of computer architecture,
different types of hardware, and you
mentioned some.
So there's actually something that was
pointed out to me by Johannes Kleiner.
So he pointed me to the notion of
computation and memory or something
similar, and if I understand that
correctly, it is a slight departure from
the Van Norman architecture because you
actually do computations within the
memory unit.
So it's not that you have additional
memory units within the CPU, but you
perform computations in the memory unit
itself, which would be a way of
satisfying the Axel constant, the flow
condition that I mentioned.
And similarly, there may be other
architecture, maybe neuromorphic hardware
that also could implement simulations in
a way that satisfies the flow condition.
And as I pointed out in the presentation,
the flow condition is just one necessary
condition which is weaker than the
existential condition.
So all of these systems, even if they
satisfy the flow condition, would not
thereby also satisfy the stronger
existential condition.
But as may have become clear, I am not
completely certain about this existential
condition.
Or rather, there may be some ways in
which one can describe what's going on in
such systems that you can actually say,
okay, the processes that implement these
computations, they are systems,
particular systems to which the free
energy principle can be applied, even if
maybe the material on which these
processes run is not directly affected by
these computational processes.
So maybe if we think about maybe
neuromorphic computer chips, maybe the
chips themselves, they will continue to
exist no matter what computations they
perform.
But if what's going on, if the activity
that implements the computations within
such a chip is sophisticated enough or
has certain properties, maybe this
activity can be regarded as an instance
of a particular system to which the free
energy principle can be applied.
So I'm not completely certain about this
and I think this is something that has to
be clarified.
Maybe it will be useful also to see what
people are actually working on the free
energy principle would say about this.
That's very important point.
Daniel: Yeah, a few things that makes me
think of first is kind of like the hard
problem of virtualization or something in
that some modification of a hard or an
easy question.
And then also about the difference
between a case where the material
substrate of computation is its own self
referent sustainer and another case in
which the material basis of a computation
is projecting, let's just say a non
equilibrium steady state like a holograph
or it's creating robots, it's spinning
out robots or it's doing 3D printing.
So in that situation, depending on how
the system boundaries are modeled, the
viability of one part, maybe even like
its kind of semantic germline is required
for the continued propagation of some
other part of this persistent system.
But Thomas Parr is actually disposable
even though it's the embodiment.
I'll go to a question in the live chat
and also I think it was a mem computing
was the memory based computing
architecture.
Yeah.
And agree, there's a lot of interesting
threads there.
So Ali asks a question in the chat he
wrote, what about understanding?
If we define understanding as a kind of
correlation or mapping between spaces of
semantic possibilities?
Can we say that large language models do
indeed understand their prompts and
outputs?
And does understanding in this sense
require or entail consciousness or vice
versa?
So with understanding as a map among
semantic spaces, what can we say about
Llms and understanding?
And what is the relationship between
understanding and consciousness?
Wanja: Thank you.
That's a very good or these are very good
questions.
And of course, it depends on the notion
of understanding.
And if we conceive of understanding as a
way of grasping inferential relations or
associative relations between different
notions, there certainly is some form of
understanding that large language models
have.
They can relate concepts to one another.
And their representations of concepts in
a vector space preserves some important
parts of the structure of conceptual
spaces of our language.
So in this sense, they do understand some
things.
Then there are other forms of
understanding and about which I will say
is something in a moment, but because
that's a bit more complicated and I
cannot say as much about it, I think.
But the question whether understanding
entails consciousness or understanding in
the sense you mentioned, I would say,
does not entail, does not require
consciousness.
So you can have that without
And another question is well, does
consciousness require some other form of
understanding?
Maybe.
Or at least my proposal here would
suggest that yes, there is some form of
understanding that is required by
consciousness.
And this is an understanding which is
related to knowing what things in the
world some words or representations refer
to.
So this requires that you actually have a
concept of there being a world of which
you are part.
And I don't think that large Lagrange
models understand that they are things in
the world.
They don't know that there is something
out there of which they are a part.
And I think that's crucial for a certain
form of understanding.
And in order for certain things to be
meaningful for you, you must somehow have
a concept of the world and a sense of
that you are part of this world and how
you relate to things in the world and so
on.
Now, this, I think, is required for some
form of understanding and I think it's
also required for consciousness, at least
according to the proposal that I
presented here.
And the idea is that if a system not only
has some internal representations that it
manipulates, but if by virtue of doing so
it sustains its existence, then this puts
some very strong constraints on what the
system will do with these
representations.
So if you if you think about a self
driving car, then in principle it may
compute all sorts of things and it will
not have a meaning for the system, for
the car itself.
But if these processes are realized in a
way that the system's continued existence
depends on these computations and this
puts some more constraints on what it can
do with these internal representations
which will give such a system maybe some
form of common sense and allowing it to
draw certain inferences and avoiding
other inferences and so on.
So that would be my hypothesis that
there's a certain form of understanding
that requires these, that also requires
the conditions that I think are necessary
for consciousness.
Daniel: In that I hear a shift from
semantics and semantic embeddings to true
semiosis and the abductive process of
generation of embedded meanings.
That's very interesting.
Okay, a few more questions.
One, you've been writing excellent and
diverse papers on different mathematical
formalisms of consciousness for some
years now.
So how have you seen the empirical side
and the theoretical side of scientific
study of consciousness developing in the
last several years?
And how do you believe that the current
inflection points in artificial
intelligence are like recontextualizing
or modifying your agenda or bringing
different relevance to your work?
Wanja: Yeah, that's a good question.
And in general, I would say that since
the 90s there's been an explosion of
empirical work on consciousness, partly
also due to certain methods that were and
paradigms that were developed and then
imaging technology that improved and so
on.
So we have better ways of empirically
studying consciousness.
And so in the past years, there's been or
decades, a lot of empirical data on
consciousness has been gathered and many
things have been found out.
And I think there are two reasons for
which many people are now driven to
theoretical approaches again or looking
more closely at theoretical approaches.
The first is that data alone doesn't give
you understanding, so you need ways of
interpreting data and constraining
experiments and so on.
And I think some evidence for this is are
these recent adversarial collaborations
in which proponents of different theories
of consciousness team up design
experiments that would lead to, or could
lead to evidence which more strongly
favors one but not the other theory.
And part of why such adversarial
collaborations are needed or are
perceived as necessary by some is that in
previous years people working with
certain theoretical assumptions in mind
or with their pet theory, maybe global
workspace theory, they've been or other
theories.
Of course they've then been looking for
evidence that would confirm their
theoretical assumptions and maybe
designing experiments in a way that is
more likely to yield certain kinds of
evidence or confirming evidence,
supporting evidence for their own
theoretical assumptions.
So realizing that in order to make
progress and constrain also the class of
theories that you have, realizing that
it's important to do more rigorous
experiments and explore ways in which you
can actually find also find evidence that
disconfirms certain theoretical
assumptions.
That I think is one of the motivations
behind these adversarial collaborations
and also makes people a bit more self
conscious of the theoretical assumptions
that they're making.
Yeah, then another big issue is, of
course, that the scope of empirical and
theoretical approaches has to be
expanded.
We now have good evidence that many
animals that were previously thought to
be unconscious actually are conscious.
Animals such as octopuses.
And there's at least reason to take the
hypothesis seriously that some insects
may also be conscious, maybe bees are
conscious.
And in order to make progress here
theoretical approaches are needed to help
structure debates and determine what kind
of evidence would be supportive for
certain hypotheses or which type of kinds
of evidence would be relevant.
To answer the distribution question which
entities, which animals are conscious.
So that's one thing.
And then, of course, you mentioned
progress in AI and people are now
seriously considering what artificial
systems might be conscious and whether
some existing systems might actually
already be conscious.
And we need theories to make progress on
this or maybe not necessarily theories,
but theoretical work.
And what I and also, there's a very
difficult problem here that artificial
systems are in many ways not only unlike
human beings, but also unlike other
animals.
So whereas in research on animal
consciousness you can try and draw some
analogies between human beings and other
animals, it's less straightforward when
it comes to artificial systems and this
means that empirical research alone will
be less helpful.
We also need very sophisticated
theoretical approaches to deal with these
issues.
And there will always remain some
uncertainty just because artificial
systems can be so can be physically or
physiologically so different from
conscious organisms.
And it's not clear how best to deal with
these uncertainties.
We need theoretical approaches to make
sense of all this.
And I would say we might face the reality
at some point.
So maybe it will turn out that we won't
ever know whether certain systems are
conscious or not.
I'm very skeptical that we'll someday
find a theory of consciousness that will
tell us exactly which entities are
conscious and which are not.
I mean, integrated information theory is
a proposal for such a theory and it's for
this reason very important that theories
like IIT are being developed.
On the other hand, it makes very ActInf
prediction about what kinds of systems
can be conscious and which can't.
So it would agree with the proposal I
presented here that a computer simulation
in a classical hardware will not be
conscious and many artificial systems
will not be conscious even if they have
all the abilities that we that are
associated with consciousness, even if
they can interact with the environment,
have sophisticated cognitive abilities
and so on.
So it's very important that such theories
are developed.
But I think it's also very hard to gain
certainty.
And maybe so.
This is one strategy that I'm pursuing is
to try and find necessary conditions for
consciousness which would allow us to
rule out that certain systems are
conscious.
So maybe we will never have a theory of
consciousness that says with certainty if
a system, an artificial system has x or
X-Y-Z and so on, then it is conscious.
But maybe we will have some theoretical
approaches that are empirically informed
and which strongly suggests that if a
system does not have X, then it is not
conscious.
So maybe this will be all that we can
hope to achieve when it comes to
understanding artificial consciousness.
And I see the account that I'm presenting
here as contributing to this project by
proposing some necessary conditions for
consciousness.
And as I already indicated, I'm not
completely certain about either of these
conditions.
But maybe something like the weaker
condition, the flow condition, maybe that
would something like that could be a
useful, necessary condition for
consciousness, which would rule out
consciousness in a wide class of systems,
but which would, for example, not rule
out the possibility of consciousness in a
computer simulation.
Not in all computer simulations.
Daniel: Awesome.
The via negativa of consciousness
studies.
So one question on measurement and then a
closing question on ethics.
So you mentioned the distribution
question.
What is the distribution of consciousness
in our scenario?
What kind of distribution is that?
Is it a z axis?
There's a scalar quantity that is going
to summarize the density of some
distribution in space like we were doing
some kind of topographical map?
Or is that distribution
multidimensional?
Are there different dimensions to
consciousness?
So to what extent do we even aim for a
unidimensional scalar representation,
potentially using IIT or other measures?
Or to what extent will we have a
plurality of consciousness measures
without necessarily like a higher or
lower.
Wanja: Thanks.
Yeah, that's a very tough question as you
already alluded to.
According to some theories, such as IIT,
consciousness does come in degrees, but
it varies along a single scale, a degree
of consciousness.
And classically, there's also this
distinction between the level of
consciousness and the contents of
consciousness.
Or the level would be defined in terms of
wakefulness or vigilance and the contents
in terms of that which is experienced.
And the idea would be that you can
distinguish between levels of
consciousness in a unidimensional way.
But then more recent proposals according
to which consciousness is
multidimensional and as you already
mentioned, which means that it may be
impossible to define a unidimensional
degree of consciousness, maybe you can
only order conscious experiences along
these different dimensions individually,
but not have a total order on conscious
states.
Yeah, so I think these are, to a large
extent unresolved questions and I don't
have a strong opinion on this, but I do
think that consciousness, there are at
least some crucial dimensions of
consciousness that come in degrees.
And I'm open to the idea that there will
be borderline cases between systems that
are clearly conscious and systems that
are clearly unconscious.
So I'm open to the idea, to the
possibility that there will be some
systems for which it's indeterminate
whether they're conscious or not.
And apart from I, Dean IIT would not
imply this, of course, but there some
computational approaches to consciousness
would specify some properties.
I mean, if you think about the
counterfactual depth action, action
oriented representation instance, that's
something that comes in degrees, and it's
not clear at what point a system will be
conscious and cease to be unconscious.
What degree of counterfactual depth is
necessary for consciousness.
I'm open to the possibility of borderline
cases of consciousness.
And similarly, if we try to apply
theories of consciousness to other
animals, then there may be cases in which
it's not clear whether what a theory of
consciousness would say.
So Jonathan Birch has a wonderful paper
about the problem of trying to determine
of finding out which non human animals
are consciousness.
And the idea is that if you try to use a
theory of consciousness that was
developed on the basis of what we know
about consciousness in human beings, then
there may be many cases in which it's not
clear whether the theory applies or not,
or whether the conditions for
consciousness are fulfilled or not.
So if you think about global workspace
theory, what is a global workspace?
We can, for human beings, distinguish
between different consuming systems,
local processes that have access to the
global workspace and which receive the
contents that are represented in the
workspace and which are thereby
consciously processed.
But there are animals that don't have as
many cognitive sub processes, that don't
have such sophisticated cognitive
abilities, that may maybe have something
like a global workspace, but with fewer
consuming systems.
So when does it cease to be a global
workspace in the sense that will be
required for consciousness?
And because of such indeterminacy, it may
be more useful than to look for other
markers of consciousness, evidence for
consciousness, such as learning
abilities.
That's what Birch proposes, and in part,
I think, inspired by work by Yvonne
Jablanca and Simona Ginsburg, who
suggests that certain forms of learning
are transition markers for consciousness,
which provides strong evidence for the
presence of consciousness.
And yeah, what about the distribution
question?
So this is more about evidence for
consciousness in different types of
systems and what will the distribution
look like in the end?
I don't know.
But what I'm mainly interested is in
trying to find out how we can determine
whether a system is conscious or how we
can rule out that a system is conscious
and what, in the end, this will tell us
about the distribution of consciousness,
I think is a great open question.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, as we say in the ant colony, the
whole nest is our workspace.
So different systems will do it
differently.
And in closing, I know that you're
teaching a course on this, so to compress
it will be a challenge.
But could you conclude with a statement,
or actually a pair of statements on AI
ethics, one addressed to natural humans,
one addressed to the machines?
Wanja: Yeah.
So AI ethics so I don't want to say
anything about AI ethics in general, but
just about consciousness.
So when it comes to human beings what I
find interesting is a question what is
required for being a moral agent?
So most people would agree that
consciousness gives people or gives
entities gives organisms at least some
moral status even if it's maybe not
required for having a moral standing but
it's at least sufficient for some form of
moral status.
And then maybe some organisms matter more
than other organisms even if they are
similarly conscious.
But maybe some animals matter more than
other animals because of their cognitive
abilities and so on.
And then the question is what do we have
to add in order to turn a moral patient,
as it were, into a moral agent?
A being that can act in ways that are not
just in accordance with certain moral
principles or not in accordance with them
but that can act because of certain moral
considerations?
And is it necessary to be conscious in
order to be a moral agent?
And what I find interesting here is to
explore to what extent accounts that look
for necessary conditions for
consciousness may also yield some
necessary conditions for being a moral
agent.
So even if consciousness may not be
required for being a moral agent maybe
there are certain necessary conditions
for consciousness that are also necessary
for moral agency.
And this can then also be applied to
artificial systems in principle.
But of course, when it comes to
artificial systems the interesting
question is should we even create
artificial systems that might be
conscious or do we have a duty to create
conscious artificial systems?
And my own position would be that in the
case of animals it's already happened.
We may not know with certainty which
animals are conscious and which are not.
But regardless of our epistemic situation
regardless of what we know about these
animals they are conscious or are not
conscious.
They feel pain or don't feel pain.
They suffer or they do not suffer.
So the most we can do is to try and
minimize the suffering in existing
animals.
But when it comes to artificial systems
we can at least at the moment say that
most artificial systems are very unlikely
to be conscious.
And we have the unique opportunity now to
really think hard about whether we want
to risk creating conscious artificial
systems.
And I think we learned at least two
things two interesting things in the past
weeks or months about artificial systems
artificial intelligence and
consciousness.
And one is that AGI may not require
I think most people believe that anyway.
But there was at least a possibility that
AGI artificial general intelligence might
require consciousness.
And what we've seen with the latest
generations of language models is that
they at least come very close to some
form of artificial general intelligence
and it's very unlikely that they're
conscious.
And so this gives me at least some
confidence that future, more
sophisticated systems that will have a
general form of intelligence will also
not be conscious or unlikely to be
conscious.
And I think that's good because it will
not there will be no further incentive to
create artificial conscious systems in
order to achieve AGI, because it seems
that you can achieve that without
creating conscious systems.
Another thing which is a bit more
concerning, maybe, is that we've also
seen that it's very difficult to regulate
developments in AI, and big companies can
just decide to put systems on the market
and make them available for everyone, and
they will use them for whatever purposes
without any regulation.
And so if it will, in the maybe not too
far future, be feasible to create
conscious systems, if we do gain a better
understanding of what it would mean for
an artificial system to be conscious or
maybe how to create one, people will do
it and it will be very difficult to
regulate this.
So this may be a problem for the not too
far future.
Daniel: A problem for guest stream number
40.2.
Wanja: Yes.
Daniel: Thank you, Wanja.
Very insightful.
Best of luck with your works and hope to
talk to you later.
Wanja: Thank you, Daniel.
It's been a pleasure.
Daniel: Very well.
Wanja: Bye, you.